SECRETARY STEVEN MNUCHIN
TELL OUR OWN BRET BAIER
TONIGHT HE BELIEVES THEY
WILL FIND A WAY TO AVOID A
GOVERNMENT SHUT DOWN, JUDGE.
>> Judge: JOINING US NOW
WITH REACTION TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND BIG TAX VICTORY IS
COUNSELOR TO THE PRESIDENT
KELLYANNE CONWAY.
GOOD EVENING, KELLYANNE.
>> GOOD EVENING.
BHOIS.
>> THERE HAS BEEN INDEED
THERE SAVOY JANUARY IS I AND
VIBRANCY YOU SAW IT THERE ON
HOUSE AND SENATE.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
DIFFERENT COMMITTEES AND
REALLY THE RANK AND FILE
REPUBLICANS.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE WERE NO
DEMOCRATS THERE BECAUSE NONE
OF THEM TOOK AN OPPORTUNITY
TO OUR JOB CREATORS, TO
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES, AND
NEXT YEAR AND EXPLAIN WHY
THEY INSIST THIS IS A TAX
COMPANIES SAY THEY ARE GOING
TO GIVE BONUSES AND OTHER
CHARITABLE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THEIR EMPLOYEES.
ARE THOSE EMPLOYEES
RECEIVING THOSE HARD WORKING
MEN AND WOMEN THE RICH?
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS MISSED
A HUGE OPPORTUNITY HERE WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LEADERSHIP
THAT REALLY PUT THIS OVER
THE TOP.
>> Judge Jeanine: KELLYANNE,
GOING TO GIVE BONUSES,
SOMETHING LIKE $1,000.
>> TO 200,000 EMPLOYEES.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Judge Jeanine: HOW DO THE
DEMOCRATS SPIN THAT THIS IS
A BAD THING AND HOW LONG IS
IT GOING TO TAKE FOR PEOPLE
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS TAX
CUT, TAX REFORM IS, INDEED,
WHAT THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
SUPPORTERS HAVE SAID IT IS?
>> INDEED.
I THINK THEY WILL SEE IT
RIGHT AWAY.
AND SOMEBODY AT THE PODIUM
TODAY WAS MAKING A VERY GOOD
POINT THAT THERE ARE A
COUPLE DATES FOR AMERICANS
TO LOOK AT, JEANINE.
ONE IS JANUARY 1ST.
STARTING NEXT YEAR,
LITERALLY WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT KIND OF TAX CODE
WILL START TO SEE THEIR --
THE INCREASES IN THEIR PAY.
THEIR PAYCHECKS WILL GET
FATTER UNDER THIS PAYCHECK
PRESIDENT.
RECOGNIZE THAT MANY OF THEM
THEY WILL TAKE BACK SO MUCH
OF THOSE WASTED HOURS AND
WASTED MONEY.
THEN THEY WILL START TO SEE
MANY OF THESE BUSINESSES
REPATRIATE THE TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT ARE PARKED
OUR JOB CREATORS MORE
COMPETITIVE.
I THINK TODAY WAS A REAL
TURNING POINT IN TERMS OF
SHOWING THAT THE CONGRESS
AND THE PRESIDENCY CAN WORK
TO DELIVER FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THIS WAS NOT A CAMPAIGN
PROMISE.
THIS IS A MORAL IMPERATIVE
FOR PEOPLE TO DESERVE TO
KEEP MORE OF THEIR MONEY.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW,
WHAT IS SOMETIMES OVERLOOKED
IN THIS WHOLE THING IS THAT
THE REPEAL OF THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE, THE REQUIREMENT
THAT PEOPLE WHO DON'T BUY
INSURANCE ARE GOING TO BE
FINED BY ALL OF THOSE
ADDITIONAL HIRES AT THE IRS,
AND I ASSUME THAT THEY WON'T
BE THERE MUCH LONGER.
YOU KNOW, IS SOMETHING THAT
IS A GOOD THING?
>> SO, TODAY WAS REALLY
THREE BILLS IN ONE.
IT WAS QUITE HISTORIC ON
EVERY LEVEL.
THE TAX CUTS THEMSELVES ARE
BUT, HAVING THE REPEAL OF
THE OBAMACARE RADIO MANDATE,
CLINTON HAS ALL BEEN
FULFILLED.
TOOK THE CHANCE ON THE
OBAMACARE MANDATE INSISTING
THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL MANDATE
WOULD ATTRACT THE YOUNG AND
HEALTHY TOTE EXCHANGES DID
NOT DO THAT THE YOUNG AND
HEALTHY WERE TOO SMART.
THEY WOULDN'T DO IT.
AND THE WHOLE THING
COLLAPSED.
30 MILLION AMERICANS JEANINE
DON'T HAVE HEALTHCARE AS WE
SPEAK.
THE INSURERS ALL FLED THE
EXCHANGES.
IT BECAME PROHIBITIVE FOR
THEM.
THIS HAS TAKEN 40 YEARS FOR
AND PRESIDENTS BUSHES TRIED
TO DO WHICH IS START
DRILLING RESPONSIBLY SO THAT
WE ARE MORE ENERGY DEPENDENT
ON AMERICA.
WE CREATE THOSE JOBS.
WE TAP THOSE RESOURCES.
I MEAN, SOME OF THE
ESTIMATES ARE TRULY
INCREDIBLE.
ALL OF THIS PUT TOGETHER,
AMERICA IS GOING TO SEE
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY WHAT A
DIFFERENCE THERE IS IN THE
ECONOMY.
LET'S FACE IT JEANINE, THE
TAX CUTS IN THE CENTERPIECE
OF REGULATORY ROLL BACK.
>> BOOMING STOCK MARKET FOR
>> WHAT'S INTERESTING IS
THEY SAY THAT THE BOOMING
STOCK MARKET IS -- IT'S NOT
INGE REFLECTING THE
CONFIDENCE WE ARE GOING TO
BE FACING ONCE IT HAPPENS.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THIS
DEAL ON DACA AND THE
CONTINUING RESOLUTION.
THE POSSIBILITY OF THE
GOVERNMENT SHUT DOWN FRIDAY
I BELIEVE IT IS.
NOW, DO THE DEMOCRATS --
NONE OF WHOM VOTED FOR THIS
TAX CUT.
DO THEY HAVE ANY LEVERAGE AS
IT RELATES TO THE CONTINUING
RESOLUTION AND FORCING SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO ADD BACK.
>> THEY HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF
EXPLAINING TO DO AS TO WHY
NONE OF THEM COULD ADMIT
THAT INDIVIDUALS AND
EMPLOYERS IN THEIR STATES
AND THEIR CONGRESSIONAL
IT'S VERY CLEAR THEY WOULD.
THEY WILL HAVE TO EXPLAIN
THAT IN DUE COURSE.
ON THE CONTINUING
RESOLUTION, WE FEEL
CONFIDENT AND WE ARE VERY
HOPEFUL THAT THE DEMOCRATS
WILL NOT ALLOW PETTY
PARTISAN DEMOCRATS IN WAY OF
KEEPING OUR GOVERNMENT OPEN
AND FUNDING OPERATIONS TO
MILITARY AND ELSEWISE.
ON IMMIGRATION THE PEOPLE
SHOULD REVIEW THE
PRESIDENT'S 70 POINT
IMMIGRATION PLAN JUDGE
EVERYTHING FROM DACA TO
ENDING CHAIN MIGRATION TO
MORE ICE AGENTS ON THE
BORDER SO THAT WE CAN GET
MORE SECURITY.
WE HAVE A 50% DECREASE IN
ILLEGAL CROSSINGS SINCE HE
SAYS COMES THROUGH THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
WE HAVE FENT NAIL COMING.
IN ALL OF THIS ADDS UP TO A
INCLUDING MERIT BASED
SYSTEM.
AND EVERYONE SHOULD READ IT
AND NOT FOCUS ON ANY ONE
COMPONENT.
>> WE DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
THAT DACA IS SOMETHING THEY
CAN LEVERAGE BEFORE THE
CONTINUING RESOLUTION AND
THAT THE CR WILL PASS,
CORRECT?
>> I WOULD HOPE SO, BECAUSE
THE PRESIDENT MADE VERY
CLEAR THAT HE WANTS THAT
WALL FUNDED.
THAT IS NOT NEGOTIABLE.
ISSUE IN WHO WANTS TO BRING
TO THE TAKE THEIR CHIEF
TERENCE WILL ALSO HAVE TO
HEAR HIS.
>> I WOULD SAY HE HAS THE
YOU WERE LAND HERE.
>> KELLYANNE, DO WE KNOW
WHEN THE PRESIDENT IS GOING
TO SIGN THIS BILL.
>> SIGN THE DINING
RESOLUTION.
>> Judge Jeanine: NO, NO,
HELP THE TAX REFORM.
>> THERE ARE PROCESSES AND
PROTESTS CALLS THAT NEED TOP
FOLLOWED.
I EXPECT HIM TO DO THIS OVER
THE DUPLEX COUPLE WEEKS I'M
IS A REALITY.
YOU SAW PEOPLE RESPOND BY
PASSING IT ON.
UNLIKE ALL THE PREDICTIONS,
ALL OUT BREATHLESS
ALLOW THIS TAX CUT TO
REBOUND TO THE BENEFIT OF
THE LITTLE BY GUY, OF THE
WORKER THEY WERE GOING TO
STICK IT IN THEIR OWN
POCKETS.
BEFORE THE PRESIDENT
RESPONDED IN THE SOUTH LAWN
THEY ANNOUNCED THESE
BONUSES.
THEY PREDICTED A YEAR AGO,
GLOBAL RECESSIONS, STOCK
THE OPPOSITE HAS HAPPENED.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS
LOW.
THE LOWEST EVER AMONG
HISPANICS.
LOWER FOR AFRICAN-AMERICANS
THAT HAS BEEN ABLE TO
REALIZE A PIECE OF
TOMORROW HAD VOTED ON MANY
YEARS ONLY TO HAVE IT DIE ON
THE PRESIDENT'S DESK.
SOME OF THOSE HAD VOTED FOR
THE REAGAN TAX CUTS AND THEY
THINK THIS IS EVEN MORE
BOLD.